it's been an extraordinary week in so
many ways I think first of all the
great loss to this community has
suffered has in many ways been
related to and it has resonated not just
throughout Ireland but through the Irish
people abroad and
the messages that have come have been
very important to the community but
as I listened to
for the John Joe Duffy
whom I think uh Bishop Allen mcguckian
has referred to as a rock in the
community what was extraordinary
was listening to the long detail
of the lives
of the people their different
relationships to the community the
different tasks they did people who
worked with their hands and with their
head and all of their [ __ ] of what they
shared and it reminded me of what I had
said at the very beginning in a small
community where the relationships are so
close and where people have intimate
knowledge of families and circumstances
it isn't a single person or a family
that carries the big lash of a terrible
tragedy like this but it is the whole
community
but this watch has been very moving I
must say it's president of I've been
here and and being able to take so much
of the texture of this community in all
its different manifestations and
circumstances and has been very very
very very moving I think what will
happen now is that the first reaction
was very much
of shock and of a kind of silence and
anomalous
how you to handle a tragedy of this
magnitude
and then after that there was what had
to be done in pushing things together
and making all of the arrangements and
an extraordinary cooperation came out of
daesh and then there were the memories
and the tracings of all the different
patterns of what they had shared with
different people right up to this very
last they had a five-year-old lovely
girl and her father and I I think it
showed me something very much about it
is is this how the best instincts and
the decency that people come to the
floor when they're able to share
something like this and that was I think
what will happen now is that will be the
big challenge I think is that the
funerals are over but all the vacant
spaces out there and all the losses that
were experienced and people remember and
something new will have come in its
place new relationships new connections
new functions that will happen in the
community but I'm certain that they have
all of the ingredients of the courage
and the determination to make that
something new fresh and be as valuable
as what to have lost